good afternoon
we're all here for some full stack
development
now I know the I know the theme of the
conference is software jungle and I'm
really tempted to use lots of references
into that but at the moment I can't help
myself it's November 2019 and I there's
only one reference that's valid
and that's Blade Runner although we can
do a slight adaptation here and at least
begins without but yes of course I want
to provide you though how do we get
through a jungle with a machete a clear
path and in case you're wondering how to
watch the first six Star Wars films what
is the order correct order for that a
correct order if your honor what all of
them is the machete ordering which is
four five two three six
okay go and google that one you may
notice I left out one there's about five
minutes of one that's relevant okay so
that's enough film references so that's
this way Nia um let's go to the UK so I
did this search this week on LinkedIn
full stack developer in the UK there
were seven thousand results Wow
and some of them require quite a lot of
you
you've got a passionate and driven I
presume that passion is how we get baby
developers I'd not quite sure about that
one and driven refocused in other words
we're we're not going to provide you
with any motivation you better come with
your own motivation
you better be itself self motivating is
this is really dull you're going to need
to have deep reserves of passion to get
through this
not just anger we start off by looking
at how we think about this terminology
these days we talk about this this is
term full stack development and what
I've learned is that it covers front-end
development and back-end development
that's kind of it this is called
full-stack turns out there's a little
bit more to the world than this and
there's
of other things this is not an exclusive
list but it turns out that there's a
bunch of other things that probably
qualify you see your stack goes all the
way down it's kind of all these people
whose call herself full stack developers
but it's just like have you ever done
the device driver work honestly it's not
as exciting as it sounds or maybe it
doesn't sound very exciting at all in
which case yes it is that exciting but
all of this other stuff is kind of
interesting so I guess really that's
full state development and a lot of
things get called full stack are its
from what I can tell it's here do you
know JavaScript and
Oh database
and you know I my background is in
systems programming so starting from C
but I did I did have a conversation with
somebody who said yeah you know C is too
low-level and weird
they were JavaScript program how could
they say this JavaScript turns out is
very low level for example there's the
specter and meltdown of speculative
execution in the firmware it turns out
that that manifests itself right at the
top level anyway I don't know what I'm
talking about this because that's full
stack development that's not what this
talk is about that's actually the
correct way to talk about that [ __ ]
develop what I'm here to talk about is
full stack development just slightly
different it's actually about stacks it
is about the computer science structure
a stack possibly the most overused
example in the history of computer
science it's not the most over specified
example yet
we don't fully understand it people
don't get as much from it as they can so
I want to be able to only use that today
to kind of take a round and walk through
some elements of computer science that
may be of use for you and if nothing
else they should be reasonably
entertaining so that's brilliant I love
it I have a slide later on that actually
uses more pink so I'm looking forward to
that and you can look forward to it now
so I edited this book a few years ago 97
things every programmer should know and
in it Jacy Van Winkle included this
observation this this recommendation use
the right algorithm and data structure
and this is kind of classic computer
science stuff and everybody thinks oh
how I don't really need to worry about
that but it turns out you do because it
makes a huge difference depending on the
language in the environment that you're
in how you think about these things it
turns out if you want to talk about
stacks and you kind of go back to 1960
old-school programming language Lisp
many people say well you know Lisp was
the last and first programming language
and it turns out that if you're working
in Lisp stacks are really simple just
linked lists and the primitive the whole
language is structured around primitives
for lists for stack operations it turns
out you don't have to do any work
if you've got a stack and that's a link
a singly linked list in memory then that
operation gives you the top element this
operation is a pop and cons is a push
that's it we're done we can go home that
was a quick talk but for some people
basically the last 60 years of software
development has been simply waiting for
hardware to allow you to do lists and
lists of ideas properly but
down your data structures and you got to
understand what they cost and the
concepts that are used for them
and that's concrete datatypes in
particular yeah insertion to a regular
linked list has a cost of o1u to
understand complexity but if you add a
cryptographic hash to every link and an
insertion can cost one megawatt-hour
and this is the basis of Bitcoin
blockchain and various other I call
currencies but they're speculative
assets so just as with speculative
execution there are surprises to be
helped there let's talk about that's a
concrete data structure talk about the
abstract a dispersed structure stuff
because ADT's or one of the most
influential ideas even though people
often don't work in languages that
express them directly they have hugely
shaped our thinking and this is comes
out of the work of Barbara Liskov in the
early 1970s you may recognize her name
from the list go substitution principle
yes it's that Barbara Misgav winner of
the cheering award and this paper in
1974 really talks about what do we mean
how do we reason in these things what is
the purpose of this stuff an abstract
data type defines a class of abstract
data objects which is completely
characterized by the operations
available those objects now for a lot of
people they think wait a minute this is
object orientation yeah sort of they
overlap but the fundamental idea is data
abstraction she's not talking about
anything else here
most of what we think of as being good
with their own is actually at overlaps
and comes from the ADT world the fact
they use the word object as well perhaps
as to the confusion or means that people
remember less about ADT's programmers
concerned only with the behavior which
that object exhibits but not with any
details of how that behavior is achieved
by means of an implementation so that's
kind of an interesting segue let's
actually talk about stacks so here's the
stack of books that are about objects
and the stack of books how do I talk
about it without talking about its
implementation program is a very drawn
towards the implementation sometimes
very difficult to separate people's
thinking about how do i implement
something from how is it from how do i
reason about it how do i think about it
how do I use it
this idea of usage is quite important
I'm gonna see that informs the way we
think about tests this is very unifying
subject now if I think about stack
what can I do with that stack well
there's a bunch of operations I can
create one I can push pop I can find the
debt and I can find the top element now
that's not enough to give you a model of
reasoning I can sit there and dig into
the maths into a math book and come up
with this which is just a gratuitous
excuse for me to use an upside down a
and back to front II talk this is for
all for all types of T so this is
generic there is a thing called a stack
which is basically a Cartesian product
of or it's a tracer a tagged product are
all five operations or five fields which
give you these basic behaviors and
that's great that gives me some types
we'll come back to the fact that these
guys are slashed here these are partial
functions these are full functions or
total functions a total functions can be
called at any time a partial function
basically means you can't always call
this it doesn't always mean something
useful it's not always defined and so
what is the top of an empty stack okay
that's an interesting one what happens
to I pop an empty stack that's an
interesting one so this is an idea of
undefined behavior however apart from
the types and that partial versus total
distinction this is not enough to talk
about this without an implementation
well we can go back we can sit there and
sort of sketch out a java class get
something there I guess if you're a Java
programmer you might think oh you know I
need to use the word get somewhere
because it's not obvious what depth and
top mean maybe I should put the word get
because that will help people okay
honestly I think Java programmers are
not committed enough if you're going to
do it do it okay I want to get that
ought to do this it's like really that
you should only have three prefixes in
the well maybe four if we allow is but
in all of your Java code
should we get do okay we don't we don't
want to have meaningful words we want to
fill the world with noise how I'm gonna
nor that I focus on that and then I'm
going to take you back on a journey to
1969
so fifty years ago an axiomatic basis
for computer programming Tony Hall this
is kind of like the beginning of all
methods how do I reason about behavior
okay so this is quite an interesting one
because this kind of introduces an idea
now the notation that he used in the
original paper is this bqr said as if
the assertion P is true before
initiation of a program Q then the
assertion R will be true on its
completion and these days we use
slightly adaptive notation and that is
precondition
Shin hos condition that's what that's
where all this comes from we can apply
this kind of reasoning to stack and this
gives us what has become known as the
programming by contract model which was
contrived in the 1980s by Bertrand Meyer
but it is basically just always work for
methods work just applied to regular
code what is the post condition of the
constructor well the depth is zero
that's the post condition once I called
it that's the one thing I can guarantee
what about push okay where the pre depth
is the death before you called it the
post condition is that the death is the
pre death plus one and the top is
whatever you just pushed well
Oh
recondition I'll be empty postcondition
it'll have one less element
death yeah you actually find that this
fighting
death is well it can't be negative
that's all we can say about it in the
top really we can't say very much about
it at all apparently some people get
very excited about this kind of thing I
can't get very excited about the this
program by contract model because it is
too incomplete you can't actually say
anything useful with it I mean really
there's not a lot here that you can do
this is probably one of the weakest
specifications you ever like you to see
and it's probably one of the reasons
people weren't very impressed with
formal methods I mean doesn't tell me
what was in the stack when I asked for
top I have no idea what's there
you might return something it's not very
helpful kind of hoped it would but you
know that's it now what is interesting
is that if we
switch this to C++ I could say the same
thing I've got a few tweaks
the conventions in C++ the reason I
picked to switching from Java C++ is
because C++ 23 is due to have pre and
post conditions it was due to be C++ 20
but people couldn't really agree on
certain things so yes the joy of
committees but here is what it will look
like unless they change it again in C++
23 use pre-imposed but you'll actually
see there's some stuff missing it turns
out that an already weak specification
is now almost useless because at this
point I can't really say anything about
push except I can't even say that the
depth is one greater top is going to
equal the new top that's it the post
condition of pop is that it won't be
negative
that's it what going on here is that
it's very difficult to get excited about
this and if you're actually looking very
closely you will realize as you're not
familiar with C or C++ size T is an
unsigned type it has no negative domain
so it turns out that actually some of
these are not very exciting at all and
we can get rid of them
and in a few slides time I'll show you
about potentially getting rid of the
preconditions it's almost an entirely
useless feature which is maybe why
people find so much scope to disagree
about it this is really not as useful as
it could be if you're all the examples
I've ever seen a pre imposed condition
formal reasoning require a lot more
support and even your the fact that you
can't even specify a trivial stack kind
of tells you you don't want it in
application development it's not going
to be useful there unless you can do
something else oh there is there is a
formalism to the rescue and it's used in
number places Tony Hall used it in
communicating sequential processes a
formalism for reasoning about concurrent
code let's go back and revisit one idea
we've already had stack the alphabet he
talks about the alphabet in other words
what is that what is the language or the
symbols that are available when you're
talking about stacks there you go but
instead of looking at signatures what he
then says is like I want you to imagine
a trace of all the behaviors on a stack
so on this is not exactly CSP but it I'm
borrowing from CSP heavily
what we've got here is all the possible
call sequences all the possible call
sequences you could ever have when
interacting with a stack you can create
one new you can create one and push it
you can create one and find its depth
you can create one and push and then pop
you can create one and push and then
find its top you can create you'll
notice that there's no case where you
can create one and call pop there's no
case where you can create one and call
top that simply is not allowed in the
possible traces of the universe and
possible traces you'll think wait a
minute how many possible uses of a stack
are there you may notice I've I've
aligned it a little bit of detail here
it turns out that that's quite big
infinitely big we'll come back to
infinity later not in an infinite amount
of time in a finite amount of time and
of course if you're ever kind of if
you've got a junior developer who's just
joined the team and you're not sure what
they should do you can get them to write
this out you know that'll keep them busy
they probably do with great enthusiasm
however this is where state machines
help us this is how you generate that
sequence a new one you've got an empty
stack you can ask for its death you can
push it becomes non empty then you can
call death top push and pop if you pop
and the death is one then it becomes
empty go ah this is getting a little
more helpful now what happens when you
call top and pop in the empty State
quite literally it is undefined there is
no definition of that now this is one of
those things what is undefined mean it
means we've not provided a behavior
there which is a fancy way of saying
don't do this if you've ever programmed
in C or C++ you'll be familiar with this
hey look I've got a bug in this program
instead of helping you your local C++
expert will say oh you shouldn't have
done that well thanks
that's the problem you've got undefined
behavior well I'm afraid it's now being
defined as a bug okay which is a valid
definition of undefined behavior we
didn't define it so anything is possible
we're going to see that that has some
interesting consequences later what we
normally do is we say we don't want that
let us map that to something that we've
defined
let's throw let's just say this is
illegal okay so how do we talk about it
well it turns out that we have a way of
doing this so we can reason about it
so I presented here some J unit five
code I've skipped the implementation I
just want you to focus on the names and
this kind of nesting structure is quite
powerful we've got stacks back the new
stack is empty an empty stack throws
were in Korea for its top item an empty
stack throw has been popped an empty
stack acquires death by rotating a
pushed item as its top the one that
gives you the sense of depth and non
empty stack on popping reveals its tops
in reverse order pushing in other words
this is history aware it turns out that
the pre and post condition model is not
very good with history and state change
which is probably the one thing you care
about so this is quite useful this is
quite powerful if you've ever wondered
how do I name my tests now you have an
answer test push is not the answer okay
or do test push sorry so point here is
we've now got a model here but there's
some really interesting things about
this
servation made by Jason gone Hey
given when then given when then it's one
of the common patterns of unit testing
whether TDD style or BDD behavior driven
development given when then what we call
a or triple well that's the Tony Hoare
stuff
that's that turns out this is given when
there it's the same idea there's one
unifying idea it turns out that you
don't need to know an awful lot there's
normally at the bottom of all software
development matter what the change is
there's a few basic ideas once you
realize what those are you just wait for
the next terminology shift I think we do
one about now but yeah didn't win then
now that doesn't mean that you should go
ahead and put that all over your code
all over your test code because because
it means it's not just the internal
structure it can actually you be used to
structure the nesting and hierarchy of
your tests you can write this when a
stack is created then it is empty given
an empty stack when it is query for his
top item then it throws good you can do
that but that's kind of a very excessive
use of English you can keep it shorter
but if it helps you get there absolutely
go for it but this gives you a model of
reasoning so it turns out you can use
the formal thinking you can still use
that rigorous thinking that idea of
reasoning but you're not going to end up
trapped with an incomplete formalism
like program by contract now it turns
out that one of the things you can do
here if you're trying to structure your
unit tests and people often struggle
with structuring their unit tests they
often end up with a very flat thing they
don't use nesting which is an oversight
you can do this in most testing
frameworks some form of nesting but how
you group things it turns out you can
actually use given as a grouping
construct or you know if I have common
state that I grouped my tests together
according to the common given if I want
people to focus on the common operation
then I grouped by common operation
alternatively I can group by common
outcome here all the tests were the same
outcome okay
it depends it's up to you but you've now
got three basic ideas it turns out the
given when then think actually informs
your thinking about how to reason
communicate now let's go back to this
what we've seen so far is so a very
simple kind of stank model I've added
the throws here not because that's a
good practice it really is generally
considered not to be a good one in Java
but because I wanted to emphasize the
decision that we took about what is the
result of calling something when you're
not supposed to call it so I'm going to
make that explicit here and that's
basically our interpretation of don't do
that which is the the partial function
thing if for a moment we said let's
change this let us have only total
functions this starts getting us into an
interesting space some of which overlaps
with their concerns and functional
programming the idea of total functions
you can always call it you will always
get a result okay what if we make that a
first-class citizen rather than as a
secondary design citizen what do I do
with this unwanted State shrug my
shoulders go and inform somebody that
they shouldn't have called it like that
I have an assertion throw an exception
what should I do
well here we're gonna say you can always
call pop and you can always call stack
I've got an algebraic datatype here this
is known rather excitingly as the bottom
type it basically means nothing quite
literally nothing your
when you call top you either get a value
of type T or you don't get a thing an
empty thing it turns out there's an
easier way of writing that in Java if
you're busy trying to find the key for
that symbol optional it basically means
that when I pop we effectively treat it
as nothing happens and I call top if
there's nothing there then we get
returned an empty value now what that
looks like from the point of view of the
test is let's just emphasize
an empty stack returns an empty value as
its top item an empty stack retains a
remains empty when popped so actually
this is quite nice we've actually got
tests that tell us what we're expecting
in a specification life format but
something that's communicable in natural
language now that's kind of interesting
but I want to take a different path
we've made that we've made it do this I
want to try something different I'm
going to make such a simple stack that
it's only going to have two operations
on it the ultimate minimal design you
can only push and you can only pop
where do I find my depth from well you
can actually calculate your depth we can
basically say a few things these are
called invariants the number of times I
push must be greater than or equal to
zero the number of times I pop must be
greater than or equal to zero number of
times I push is greater than or equal to
the number of times I pop that seems
reasonable and the depth is the number
of pushes minus the number of pops ice
what language is sufficiently minimal
that we can express this - so stack is a
stack surprises let's push okay let's
push some more and let's pop and what we
should get is 2019
let's pop again what we should get is
build stuff nice okay let's try a
different usage rather there is the
implementation before we try the
different usage it's not very exciting
we're just going to use a built-in list
it does most of the work for us and
that's it we're kind of done here that
was very exciting
what happens when we owe what we
actually get is an indexing error even
though we've got no concept of index
that comes from the underlying list
fortunately it happens to have the right
vocabulary not from an empty list you
can't do that but we have a problem
there is strictly this is an incorrect
interpretation of our specification
because now I've popped so pop is now
greater than 1 it is 1
and the number of pushes must always be
greater than pops that's false because
we've not pushed and the death is 0-1 so
the death is minus one
damn this doesn't work
what we need is to change this so that
when we're non-empty we provide two
operations where empty we only provide
one operation and I have a dynamic
interface this is a property that we can
get away with and Python this is the
original the origin quote for why we
call this duck typing see a bird that
walks like a duck and swims like a duck
and quacks like a duck I call that bird
a duck I think this was written in some
bird-watching guide from the 1930s we'll
come back to the 1930s later and but
because we like animals as it's a jungle
right I've got monkeys as well in Ruby
Python and many dynamic Pro languages
the term monkey patch anywhere refers to
dynamic modifications of a class or
module at runtime
excellent self-modifying code that's
what we want so let's actually see how
are we going to do this in a way that
satisfies the original specification and
learn an extra bit about Python
enclosures as well well we've got a
class stack it's only got one method
I'm not familiar with pison the init
method is the kind of the constructor
it's the bootstrap method what we're
going to do inside that is we're going
to define four operations the first push
at the end to push the end pop in the
last pop
what you do and then what we're going to
do is once we've our last active
initialization is that our pull-push
self dot push will be the first push
because obviously the only thing you can
now do is the first push hey there are
no other operations available
what happens once you've done the first
push is that we will it now replace the
push operation with a new operation an
nth push because we've done the first
one but now it's going to be N equals
two three four etc and the pop operation
will now be the last pot because if it's
the first push it must be the last pot
last in first out and it's whatever last
pot turns for top the nth push when you
push then the pop gets reinstalled as
the end up the nth pot this is where it
gets fun we make a note of our own old
pop operation then we've got a new pop
operation that returns our local
variable axis closure and then we return
the new operation and then the last pot
so far again so what we actually end up
doing is we end up creating a linked
list of operations in memory that are
joined by scopes okay so if you wondered
about nested scopes turns out nested
scopes are far more powerful and you've
been given them credit for languages
like C sharp and Java so what that means
in practice is we now push exactly the
same as before identical behavior of
your running unit tests on this you get
exactly the same results okay now it
gets exciting
we're gonna Paul
now you see it's all there there is no
attribute pop we are unable to call pop
the number of times we have called pop
is zero because there are no pop
operations finally we've satisfied the
specification excellent not Social Work
don't do this at work okay but this is
one of those things of like if you
really want to abuse a language and you
really win people say oh I understand
stacks do you do you understand that
you're doing very well because that
mixes a number of more more advanced
concepts all together in one place okay
so give your brains a breather from that
table with full stack develops as you
can't push them
about stack an idea that is often
related and talked about when we talk
about stacks is queues and these are
different these differ by discipline it
turns out if you understand stacks and
queues you probably understand most of
the things you will ever need to know
okay
people say oh yeah is that true well
yeah it is so a queue would be like
people queuing for drinks that was mean
a few years ago I've recovered by my
co-author Frank Cushman and Mitch he
hanging he did a lot of work on Moodle
web that still does a lot of work with
middleware I believe there's a nice
queue of drinks there for us but we need
to understand why is it the queues are
so powerful as a construct and where are
we going to get two stacks again but
don't worry we'll come back two stacks
so a queue is a way of all queue models
break down to a producer and a consumer
on a queue in the middle this doesn't
mean they're distributed it doesn't even
mean that concurrent if you're bored of
the term queue I offer you a new
profound insight an alternative piece of
terminology a queue is a spacetime
decoupling okay that is way more
interesting okay when you're having a
conversation with your colleagues your
car looking at stuff it's like yeah
we're getting all these requests in what
we need here is a spacetime decoupling
sounds so much better a queue is heard
of cubes message queues all your
products all the products tend to have
queue in them and because Q is also the
name of a letter in English they all end
in queue I think that was probably cute
the first time you know maybe in the
1970s but we're kind of over that these
days we should be looking at space-time
D couplings much more exciting because
that's what it is because you queue
something up and I you come back to it
later
or it's something separate spatially
such as a different process or both
right now how do we understand them
you have sizes which means they're
buffered bounded an asynchronous for n
is greater than zero
generally infinities not recommend it
this is everybody's default idea of a
queue it just you just keep on pushing
things into it there's one problem
your computer
even the ones in the cloud that's not
your computer their computer
the cloud has only got finite resources
cannot rely on this you need to put a
boundary because otherwise something
will eventually run out it will have a
rather nasty side effect on your coat
and your runtime so always work with
bounded cues but it gets more
interesting when we think of limiting
cases what is a queue with one element
yeah we have a name for that it's called
the future
and what's the other side of it called
its called a promise turns out like I
said there are only a few ideas yeah
once you understand oh okay now I've
understood pretty much everything there
is to do with concurrency at all in fact
if what about N equals zero it son but
it's synchronous that means it's a
rendezvous the default way of
interpreting this often people use a
slightly different term here so channel
channels were basically popularized by
the CSP which we've already met and the
idea of how to reason about sequential
processes is they communicate by
channels this is a surprisingly powerful
construct so yeah we shall observe the
convention that channels are used for
communication in only one direction in
between only two processes really nice
simple way of doing it so sometimes cues
can be fed from multiple things so
distinction is that a channel should
only have on destination one producer
and one consumer it's a sip it's a
linguistic distinction but it can be
quite powerful now the language that
people often associate with channels
these days and this kind of approach is
go so let's go and have a look at a
stack and go but this time I'm going to
do this I'm going to treat the stack as
a separate running go routine
effectively a mini process I'm going to
create a channel for Strings that is
going to be for pushing having a create
another channel called pop that is going
to be for also for Strings but that's
where I'm going to get results back and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
launch a function called stack with
these two channels I'm not going to do
with the stack identity at any point in
time I'm just going to communicate with
effector via concurrent running function
which is kind of cool so the way I use
it I push or rather I've used the name
so that's suggestive I send on to the
push channel build stuff I send 2019 on
to that and when I do a print then this
is a read from the pop channel see I get
2019 and when I do receive then I get
build stuff brilliant
question is given that again I've gone
for this minimal you you go hang on I've
grown you got push and pop what about
the other operations what happens
if I try and pop an empty stack
hmm turns out there's an answer to this
we can find this in the original CSP
paper which I think was 1978
the delay we never will never be ended
for example if a group of processes are
attempting communication but none of
their input and output commands
correspond with each other there is no
send trying to receive if it's nothing
there
we have a name for this and guess what
this is a valid implementation defined
behavior so we're going to say you're
not allowed to do that this is one of
those points where your colleague comes
over and says oh you should have done
that but I've got a problem yeah you
shouldn't have that problem because of
the things that you've done but if you
don't do the things that you did then
you won't have that problem Thanks
what does that look like in code so
here's the notation I stack I've got an
input channel an hour I've got an input
channel an output channel push and pop
I'm gonna use the same names here is my
actual representation what we've done
here if you like is we've turned a
function into an object here is the
representation and this function is
going to continue executing but how long
Oh forever and continue forever
and this is the first bit if it's empty
if the depth is zero then the only thing
we can do is receive on the push channel
somebody must be pushing to us we are
not listening to any questions about pop
they are dead to us or they are dead log
to us okay now I've got the alternative
what if it's not empty well in that case
I could be I'm waiting for two things
I'm selecting on either somebody wants
to push to us in which case I'm happy to
receive it and I will append it to my
internal variable items so what I've
done is I've took and taken a local
variable it's now so local there's a
private instance variable like you want
to use that like [ __ ] and then if
somebody wants to pop from us then what
we'll do is we will give them the last
element and then we will resize
ourselves accordingly so now we're
running concurrently this is quite nice
in fact we actually see an example of
how the concurrency works because we
actually return the pop value before we
actually decrease our own size
so we kind of like here's your result
I'll get on with the housekeeping later
even though it's one statement later
now this is all very nice it's very
iterative it's very procedural go is a
very procedural language if you're
wondering about the paradigm go is a
procedural language with a few extras
top at it on top it's not an
object-oriented languages it's not a
functional language predominantly
procedural but it has this idea of the
channel based programming
procedural coding is often associated
with iteration but if you want to get
functional you need to recurse and
recursion that is truly that that will
make your colleagues stand in awe of you
so what's that going to look like here
that's going to look like this we're
going to forever loop around the
non-empty stack we're not listening to
so basically the first thing we do is we
receive a push when we've received it we
are now non-empty in the non-empty
example we've got this and what we do is
that when we receive a push
we call ourselves again non-empty if you
like what we're now doing is we are
representing ourselves on the call stack
it really is a stack okay we've got no
rep you'll notice I've not kept any
local variables except the argument so
we've actually modeled the stack using a
stack yeah and see that and then we
return from that now that's kind of cute
it's not very go like but you can do it
in go
is this not safe for work well this also
teaches us something else
be very unusual for a go programmer but
if you're working in Erlang that's
exactly what you would do it would look
exactly like this you would use
recursion in this way you would use this
kind of replacement behavior exactly in
this way which teaches us one thing
whenever people say this is a good
practice or a bad practice always be a
little bit suspicious
it might be a poor prop bad is a very
strong word normally it's context
dependent other things we often don't
appreciate is the practices depend the
quality of a practice depends on where
it is used and it turns out that what is
a good practice in one language may
actually be a poor practice in another
and vice-versa so here this turns out to
be a a different idiom a different way
of thinking but one thing we're not
going to forget is that we need to test
testing is a good thing generally so how
are we going to test the behaviors that
we've got here
this is kind of interesting actually we
we slam straight into a philosophical
problem
so we're going to get our two channels
we're going to launch a stack and now we
are going to test it with a select
statement and what we're going to do is
we're going to try and pop now if I can
pop anything if the pop operation is
successful then it means that it's
incorrectly implemented we should not be
able to pop stack is empty we're not
allowed to pop so if anything comes back
from the pop up or from the pop channel
that test fails the test how do we know
we succeeded well here you need a weight
statement we need to wait for others or
other infinity damn by the way just to
clarify this is not available in go if
there is no eternity although sometimes
things can feel like that software
development there is no eternity you
cannot say well if we succeed in waiting
forever then this code worked I mean you
could try that with your boss there you
are sitting with your feet up on the
desk looking at pictures of cats on the
internet and it boss says what are you
doing I'm saying why I'm waiting for the
test to succeed well you have a bit of a
problem here but we can approximate it
I'll say one second is normally enough
so one second can feel like an eternity
this is true but what you have just
encountered is a rather interesting
problem it is related to a thing we call
the halting problem which is can we
decide automatically whether or not a
piece of code will terminate okay and it
turns out that that's quite a difficult
problem it has no solution or other you
know it's a there's no way of
determining in advance this will not
work and therefore that will have failed
or will have passed sorry so except
we've discovered a solution we put a
timeout in
at a finite time out this is how you
solve the halting problem for a finite
time at something that means that every
operation will either have a
well-defined value outcome or it will
timeout it might be a little bit not
non-deterministic but you know at least
you've solved the halting problem you're
wondering about why is this actually a
useful concept this relates to a number
of things when you're doing network
programming and things like the cap
theorem and the idea of availability and
has a direct consequence now it turns
out that the halting problem is part of
a family of issues that can be a one
level considered philosophical there are
limits to our knowledge what can we know
what can we prove perhaps focus atoms
put it best in Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy that we demand rigidly defined
areas of doubt and uncertainty and it
turns out that we have plenty of these
in the substrate or computer science
there are a bunch of things that are
simply not provable and it's this kind
of quest in maths and eventually they're
part of mastered founded computer
science that led people like a long sigh
chair well it relates to girdle's
theorem Alonzo Church was exploring this
in the 1930s it's part of the and shiny
links problem an unsolvable problem of
elementary number theory how do we
reason about stuff can we find out
whether or not we can prove certain
statements are they all provable why is
I why my Holliston is paper because this
is where he invented lambda calculus or
rather he invented in a previous paper
but the 1936 paper is the one and that
is quite key now this is quite
interesting because a lot of people have
been game very excited recently about
the fact that their programming
languages have been adding Landers it's
just like yeah so Java since 2014
you can now program like it's 1936 also
so lambda calculus is a really old idea
but it's older it's it's deeper than you
think it's rather good paper from 2009
on understanding data abstraction by
William cook
also an understanding data protection we
visited he goes back to a 1987 paper on
understand data abstraction he makes
this observation land calculus was the
first object-oriented language that's
kind of interesting
and we actually see examples of that
when we think about scopes and if we go
back to the early 70s in this classic
book on structured programming there is
an observation there
one of the most powerful mechanisms for
program structuring is the block and
procedure concept
procedure which is capable of giving
rise to block instances which survive
its call will be known as a class
instances will be known as objects of
that class
that's pretty indeed so in other words a
block instead of being discarded when
you leave function because it's a stack
after all you've left the function you
pop something off the stack you lose the
scope what if you keep the scope and
pass it around and it has its own
identity instances of that object will
be known as class well of this will be
known as class's cool right so um it's
the JavaScript so what I can do is like
a very pure it turns out hiding inside
JavaScript is a very pure object model
it's and it's really not got out people
won't let it they keep adding other
things to the language but what I can do
is I can say I have a function that
returns a thing and I've got a private
piece of state it's a list items on a
right rather I return something that
holds the depth the top the pot these
are all themselves lambdas that refer to
the local state and this is quite neat
so what I do is I selectively return a
set of operations and the data which was
local variables is held truly privately
it's so private is actually hidden
inside a scope now this is quite an
interesting idea this is a very pure
object model there is no hacking past a
public private boundary using things
like reflection this is a proper object
model in this sense so this is quite
neat ok but that's there's more to
object orientation than this we've got
the data abstraction aside what about
the inheritance side well back in the
early seventies it wasn't really called
inheritance late 60s and early 70s and
the terminology that was used or the
stimulus 67 language was concatenation
concatenation is an operation defect
between two classes a and B and results
in the formation of a new class or block
concatenation consists of merging the
attributes both components and the
composition of their actions well
actually this is fairly easy given that
JavaScript is it's fairly duck typed now
what we can do is we can actually have
change our language a little bit and say
well where I got is a stackable property
I'm going to take an object it'll be my
base now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to overwrite I'm going to add
or or override existing methods with new
behaviors so that's kind of neat so what
that looks like in practice is that my
new stack operation now just becomes a
stackable of well we'll start with
nothing so now you've got this idea that
I can the idea of inheritance is
actually a function based operation
and let us also add in extra behavior
perhaps we wanted to be clear about as
well and not apart from just push and
pop I can also clear it ok we'll add
this one in so now I can now create my
new stack so that it is stackable and
clearable I could even tidy up the
operations and say multiple inheritance
or multiple composition using some bits
and pieces here a style of programming
that we're encouraging here or pursuing
is known as mixin program this became
this was kind of effectively invented in
the 1980s in the list of community when
they were exploring object-oriented
systems so
how do we use it well concept
hierarchies the construction principle
involved is best called abstraction we
concentrate on features common to many
phenomena we abstract away features too
far removed from the conceptual level of
which we are working it's pretty cool
now how do we what does that mean in
practice for how you organize class
hierarchies so there's one thing as a
consultant that I can tell you is
whenever I see anybody using inheritance
there's a pretty good chance they're not
using it well they're using it for code
reads
it probably doesn't make a lot of sense
it turns out we've got a we've got a
guiding principle obelisco for going in
our 87 paper type hierarchies composing
subtypes and super types the intuitive
idea of a subtype is one whose objects
provide all the behavior of objects of
another type super type plus something
extra and she had a more rigorous
formalization of it
such there is an object type etc etc
okay does that look like practice well
let's add a new operation or a new
capability that's mixing a new
capability but my stack aren't gonna
have the idea of a non duplicate top
what does that mean it means that when I
push on to stack and it already has that
value then it won't bother pushing the
new one again okay so if I push a and I
push B and I push B again it'll just the
a and B okay so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to mix this behavior in and it
turns out one of the things that the
Liskov substitution principle so Barbara
Liskov coined this in 1987 but it was
popularized by Jim Killeen in 1992 as
LSP we can write a test it turns out
that this is one of those principles you
can actually write tests for and
actually demonstrate whether or not
something passes that meets LSP just by
writing a test so here I've got a set of
tests and non-empty stack becomes deeper
by retaining a pushed item as its top so
I'm gonna push build stuff push 2019
push 2019 stack death is equal to three
if you're not familiar with JavaScript
if you're not something to be considered
equal to something else you have to
really really want it to be equal just
keep your finger down on the equals key
it'll eventually be equal enough and so
therefore what we're saying is stacks
have this property you push three things
you've got three things okay the number
of pushes minus the number of pops is
the depth okay so that's simple and very
and the top should be 2019 now if we
apply this to a clearable stackable
object and it passes it's green if
however we apply it to something the mix
in the non duplicate behavior which
basically says you cannot have this
although we might call it a stack and
it's going to like a stack it's not a
snack according to our definition our
definition says you push three things
you go through things
anything else is a violation so it turns
out that although sometimes things some
of these principles like LSP can seem a
little abstract actually they're quite
concrete you are they are testable
they've got a very specific meaning now
I want to close by zooming out of this
stuff because we've looked a lot of
stuff which is kind of very computer
science cs4 a specification oriented we
may have learned a couple of things
about programming language design a
couple of ideas about crazy things that
we don't want to do at work or things
that we can now use in code reviews you
know you can talk about space-time
decoupling so we can just tell people
instead of don't do that you can say I
you can do that if you were you know and
now you can spout a whole load of pseudo
maths out it's great so that perhaps
improves your ability to communicate
crazy ideas but we all need to
understand where this lives so I'm gonna
close by considering a framework from my
alignment from a paper he wrote in 1980
we can characterize code as SP or e
what we've been looking at
the function is formally defined by an
arrival from a specification stack
sorting routine like an accountancy
system turns out the rules of
accountancy a classic in this sets turns
out a lot of domains have a well-defined
set of rules okay and if somebody gave
you that set of rules I'm not saying
that developing software is trivial but
you could write tests against that and
you could say we have a very clear idea
of what is a right answer and what is a
wrong answer
if somebody says in a banking system
I've just pushed I've just put 100 euros
into that account then if that account
is only credited 99 euros and 99 cents
that's not close that's wrong okay
technical term for that is wrong so you
know where as I know there's a lot of
developers go that's almost a hundred
that's close enough no banking has a
very clear idea of the right and wrong
answer so these are all s-class systems
a lot of the stuff that we do certainly
the small parts is s based we can
definitely say if I told you what the
problem was you might doesn't mean
you're gonna code it instantly but I can
tell you I can give you a good idea of
what I'm expecting in terms of unit
tests and correctness it gets more
interesting when we look at P the
acceptability of a solution is
determined by the environment in which
it is embedded this moves us actually
curiously enough ELO's has written in
1980 which is five years before back
propagation in neural networks who was
established by Rama hoc Cleland this is
actually a very good way of thinking
about how we reason about machine
learning we don't know what the answer
should be
and there's no fixed way of saying that
is the right answer and that is wrong
well one way of doing it is let's put
the system into production and see if we
get lots of bad press if you get lots of
bad press then that's probably be wrong
but again you need a time machine to
negotiate to go back to yourself and say
don't do that in other words it means
that the outcome is negotiable
this is kind of interesting because with
an S system the outcome is not
negotiable we know what the right answer
should be we're not necessarily sure how
to build it what we've said here is
we're not sure what the right answer is
and we're not sure how to build it so it
opens up it's negotiable this is very
different class of problem and thinking
programs programs that mechanize a human
or societal activity program has become
a part of the world it models is
embedded in it that means the outputs of
the program will change the world the
result of the world will change the
inputs to the program this is kind of
big well actually quite small means this
relates to everything from any car any
software that you use in a car to social
media it turns out that those little
pieces of code that we find correct and
it's the classic stuff of computer
science we often focus in and say yes
I've got this the unit test pass or I've
formerly proven in very rare cases this
behavior what it tells us is that that's
still a lot of full-stack
the stack stuff is turns out there's
more you if you really want to
understand how your code works you know
it's just two lines of code understand
it's applicability you have to go
outside after kind of look the full
stack really does take in and the world
and the people around it anyway I hope
that's been fun enlightening curating
you can use some crazy ideas for
something you might want to check in on
Monday and don't blame me you can't you
can't you know allowed to commit with my
name I saw this at a talk and build
stuff I think self-modifying code is the
way to go
also let's encourage people to deadlock
code please don't blame me but thank you
very much
oh I've got one question where did you
get that amazing shirt yeah this is I've
got a whole line of weyland-yutani
shirts at home from alien I honestly I
can't remember which which one this was
it might have been ooh but also what a
feeling it might have been my second
Australia to t-shirt thank you
[Applause]